hey don't worry technician I'm Gregg
Elba
then I'm Sean I'm very late to watching
the punish the truth because it was
fixing my car again started in the car
no are lawfully victory actions muchas
gracias Senor eat doesn't send you
artists to everyone who's been following
I sort of patron page shattered it out
here right now because we do weekly q
and A's and TV show reaction watch along
for shows like my hero academia
Fullmetal Alchemist Brotherhood attack
on side and super the natural goth ham
and also Riverdale but we got some
things of the pipeline that we want to
be covering soon don't know if we're
gonna cover the punisher it's a bit of a
slow burn will consider it this is the
photoshoot
[Music]
[Music]
is healing well
Josh Stewart playing a guy named John
Pilger it was great yeah he looks almost
fine
[Music]
people died
[Music]
that looks like practical blood bathroom
five yeah that'll break a sink over some
dudes face
[Music]
[Music]
Marvel humor ah self-awareness there
might be some action in that show Wow
somebody might get get hurt for starters
they have amped up the punishment for
sure on this one man that's something
it's gonna just go a lot crazier in the
last season the first season was very
much a slow burn oh yeah oh yeah so much
slower than I even anticipate it but it
was especially in the beginning like
getting off the ground was like that
first like six or so episode everybody
no no it's cool way to take off but you
know it's got some good ideas good actor
everything's is gonna be like twice as
bad [ __ ] in this one I like plots of
victim of plot females dig vamp who need
action hero to help them out badass guy
with a penchant for brutal murders is
now looking after young woman usually
blonde I think it's actually smart to
bring back Billy jigsaw in this one I
mean obviously they set him up to be
jigsaw in this season it is smart to
bring him back because when you watch
season 1 and how that ends you go
where's the room for Frank to grow now
you know yeah it seems like it's ending
on a path or he should leave this life
behind is but you know the recovery is
not as simple as that his version so
still being haunted by the past in that
element I'm kind of bothered by the fact
that the guy who plays jigsaw looks so
good I like I got it I got to give it to
Punisher war zone like that's what I
think of when I think of jigsaw like his
face is destroyed and in this one it's
kind of like every movie where they're
like I'm so ugly with my perfectly
playschool Scott you know he's got like
a couple scars which sucks I mean it
looks like he's gonna be wearing a mass
that resembles the jig yeah it looks
like his gang is Hollywood Undead you
know you see what happens in the first
season rapes his whole family that's
amazing surgery all the damage I thought
it would be cool that if the first
season everyone's talking about how
pretty he is and you know I watch this
whole show my girlfriend she's a whole
time she's just like masturbating
ejaculating her pants guy and and then
you like mess up it's maybe they bring
it back here you're like edgy pretty I
actually read a whole interview with
Josh Stewart a lot last week I think I
read it I forgot most of it but the big
takeaway I got from reading that
interview
he's like an all right Christian
character and he's not exactly just evil
he's not just full-blown evil I mean
obviously he's an antagonist here but he
doesn't believe that was so cool to read
that is a very lengthy interview I think
I read it from Collider and the way he
does talk about it who's never just very
one note about everything he was
answering like this character is someone
who just has a very specific set of
beliefs and he's living by those beliefs
he yeah you know to such a degree that
it conflicts heavily with Frank castles
believe that's the way how it was at
least being described in this interview
so this is much of an ideological battle
as it is probably a physical one I'm not
exactly sure because you know they have
to be a little bit discreet in terms of
plot mechanisms but from what I was
hearing that made me go wow that's that
sounds like a really unique take to have
for a define villain this season around
and to be working alongside with jigsaw
I mean the action does look cool it does
look a lot better I did see that
who's that Twitter guy that rule falls
Daniel or PK or something I think so guy
who you get like this ruler was coming
out that dude he did say that he wasn't
a fan of this season that he already
caught it there's a letdown I don't know
how much notes they're taking from the
reaction of the first season are they
gonna you know amp up the energy this
time around because that first season
starts off really
slow and then gets more quicker as the
season goes and the vibe I'm getting
here is that this is gonna go like
full-on brutal throughout you know yeah
I mean this seemed pretty insane and
like there's some kind of chase element
or something cuz it looks like they're
out on the road or something you know
yeah as well as you know all this other
chaos going on in the flashbacks and all
that it could have like a kind of
percolating tension the whole series you
know hopefully anyway this season
actually kind of reminds me of Dexter
Season 5 I know you haven't seen Dexter
but the plot of that season woman was
well I mean that one she's assaulted
she's a victim she's a victim and then
she uses Dexter's help to go after the
men to get revenge and that's what we're
getting here you know like she's not
assaulted but it sounds like a lot of
people if she loved were killed and now
they're gonna go get revenge it's a plot
we've seen a lot of movies but even like
a reflection of Dexter being a killer
and then you got Frank Castle who's
definitely a killer yeah they seem like
they have this theme of you seem like
you like actually doing this and
daredevil he had a purpose cuz he's hurt
season 1 he's looking for closure and
then here it's like what do I do now now
that I've completed my mission he still
has this void in him I hope they still
keep it as character piece I like the
themes of dealing with PTSD in the first
season I'm wondering if they're gonna
continue that thematic element or if
they're gonna explore other elements or
if it's gonna be a full-on action show I
gotta imagine that they're gonna bring
in at least some character stuff just
because like I was really excited to see
Josh Stewart partly because he's kind of
like Logan marshal green for me where
I've seen him in a bunch of anything but
I think he always brings a lot of layers
to his characters and stuff like that I
feel like he's an actor you would hire
if you want somebody who's gonna be able
to give you both a physical presence and
a pretty strong emotional palette yes
and especially since he's like the new
character and I get the sense he's you
know one of the main probably
antagonists I feel like that will create
some interesting character tension
hopefully anyway and of course you know
there's a bathroom fight yeah gotta have
your obligatory bathroom fights every
time they set foot in a public restroom
know that
that's a new action trope in the
bathroom before I wrap this up I want to
give a patient the day shout out to a
handsome man named Derek Mitchell Erica
and I had some rough patches this last
year I know towards the end of 2018
it was rough but 2019 you're gonna kick
this year's you know what you're gonna
do you're gonna punish last year's ass
by kicking this year's ass that's what I
do with people if someone hurts me I
take it out on someone else and that's
what you're gonna do with this year 2018
sucked 2019 you're gonna destroy it I
don't know if I'm implying that you're
gonna cause damage or harm to other
people and yourself or you're gonna make
a lot of positive strides in your life
whatever the case is you're gonna make
an impact and that's what matters most
personally I'm rooting for a little bit
of both because you need tension in your
life I think you should start off dark
yeah then get even started start off as
Frank you know get out there let your
heavies out then you know get into your
micro Jam for a little while mellow out
and then just go full on you know
Punisher or jigsaw whichever one you
want subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell and oh
check us out on patreon
we got goodies there's dust here see you
guys